yet another Wildfire out of control in
the araucania region firefighters call
for more help unable to contain this
Blaze one of hundreds of active fires
that have been spreading throughout
South Central Chile since late January
the commander of the firefighting
Brigade tells his men to evacuate
the situation here is very complex the
fire is advancing very fast so we are
withdrawing to a safer area while we
review another strategy this helicopter
is trying to douse water on the Flames
here but it's barely a drop in the
bucket as you can see it's just simply
not enough to deal with the magnitude of
this fire here on this mountain or Hill
which the fire goes way over onto the
other side and they're only about a half
a dozen firefighters here right now the
the smoke is is really impossible to
Breathe Here
weeks of intense heat and strong winds
compounded by years of drought are
feeding the Flames but that's not all
right
the neighbors said they saw three people
with balaclavas who started the fire
back there and other neighbors say they
saw a green car and a pickup truck
starting fires while they try to put out
the fires in one area they saw how the
people in cars lit others all over the
place
[Music]
Daniela shows us the house where she
grew up and where her eight-year-old
grandmother lived until Tuesday
the vast majority of the fires have
started in forests owned by Timber
companies who've long been targeted by
Rebel indigenous mapuche groups and who
carry out what they call acts of
sabotage against Chilean companies and
farmers
they claim this as their ancestral land
but so far no one has taken
responsibility for the fires which are
hurting ordinary residents many of them
also mapuche
what hurts most is that this was the
last thing left of my deceased
grandfather he built all this with the
sweat of his brow
the loss in property livestock and human
life is incalculable at least 30 people
have been arrested for negligence or for
deliberately lighting these fires a
curfew is also in place from Midnight to
5 A.M
but nothing seems to be enough to stop
new towers of blowing smoke from
emerging
cnuman Al Jazeera galvanino Chile